-You know our next guests as Pam
and Angela from "The Office."
Their book, "The Office BFFs:
Tales of The Office from Two
Best Friends Who Were There,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome to the show
Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, you guys.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Hi! It's so fun to be here.
-This is usually
the time of year
where I would see you guys,
because you obviously shot
"The Office" in L.A., but we
both had NBC shows and upfronts,
which happened today.
You would often come out,
maybe to the "SNL" beforehand.
And you had a picture of
your New York party days,
and it's so cool,
'cause it's the two of you
and B.J. Novak,
but it looks like it could be
the three of us.
-Yeah, you know,
we are sober in that picture.
Totally sober.
-We are, I swear.
-Really?
-Totally.
-You're gonna
double down on that?
-No, we were.
We love the dance floor.
Seth, you might remember,
at that upfronts,
'cause you were there,
that Jenna and I
made up a dance where
we filed papers in the cabinet.
-We're gonna show --
Let's do it.
-We did this!
-Oh, this is great.
-Okay.
-Okay. It goes like this.
Ready and --
-Okay.
-Oh, oh, oh. Oh, I got it.
-That's great. Very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Very on-brand. Very on-brand.
I will say, I've been to
a lot of upfronts parties,
and you guys definitely did
the only dance
that was thematic to your show.
And that was really
appreciated at the time.
-We like to do that.
-So, you're going back.
This podcast is
you guys recollecting
your time together on the show.
Obviously, you were both there
the whole time.
How often do
your memories differ?
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, when we started
writing this book,
there was one that
came up right away,
which was when you --
She got us backstage at
the Emmys, on the actual stage.
-Here's what happened.
-Now, listen, here's the thing.
She was hungry.
-I don't like
to be hungry, okay?
I'm not one of those actresses
that doesn't eat food.
I like to eat the food
and I eat a lot of food
and I was very hungry.
-Sure.
-Yeah.
-And we couldn't find food
anywhere, so I said,
"Angela, come on, we've got to
get something to eat."
So I found this nice lady,
and she had a headset
and a clipboard.
-Yeah. She walked very fast
and she kept going,
"shh, shh, shh!"
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
And she took us
to this little, like, tent,
like, a dimly lit tent.
-It was not a tent.
It was a giant curtain on
the Emmys stage.
The, like, Emmy presenters
and people were right there,
and she was like "Shh!"
-But there was a whole,
like, charcuterie station
and there were these cookies.
-Yeah.
And, so,
but we didn't realize --
we were -- I forgot this story
when we were writing the book.
Angela said, "We have to tell
about that time that
Laurence Fishburne
was giving us stink-eye
because you were
eating the salami next to him."
-I mean, I vaguely heard him
say something like,
"Who the 'F' are these folks?"
And then I said,
"Jenna, wrap it up.
Shove that salami."
Oh, wait. That sounded bad.
But you know what I mean.
Like, just --
-Yeah.
-That's what she said.
-Yes!
-There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thematic. Thematic.
You guys -- But, now,
this is very interesting,
because I've talked to many of
your former castmates,
all of whom have said that
they are more recognized from
"The Office" now than they were
when the show was on NBC.
Like, people have found the show
over the years a great deal.
Now, yet, it was a hit
when it was on TV.
Did you guys --
when did you realize
that it was a hit for you guys
when it was airing?
-At the time?
-Yeah.
-It was -- We were almost
canceled every week
for almost
the first two seasons.
-Yeah.
-But I remember --
What do you think?
-The Christmas episode.
-Yes, of Season 2.
-Mm-hmm.
-But that was because
they put it on the iPods.
-Remember iPods?
-You could download it
on to your iPod,
and we were
the number-1-downloaded show.
So people were not actually
watching us live on television.
-They were watching it
on the iPod.
And we were like, "Well, we
might have a job for a while."
And I went out
and I bought a Honda, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Mm-hmm. I know.
-Yeah.
That's when we knew, when we saw
Angela in the Honda.
We're like,
"That show's working."
-Yeah.
One of the things
you guys write about,
which is fascinating to me,
because, obviously,
everyone in this cast was often
in the background of scenes,
more than any other show
you could imagine.
What did you put into
your background acting?
And did you approach it
the same way?
-Well, I did a lot of
journaling in the background
and I wrote my grocery lists
in the background,
because our computers didn't
work for the first two seasons.
They were props.
-They were just a plastic box.
-Did they eventually start --
In the third season, did they
give you a working computer?
-Yes. We got Internet.
-It was such a big thing.
They gave us a memo that said
"Today, you have Internet."
I was so excited, I saved it.
-She wanted to put it
in the book,
and I said,
"Angela, I just don't think
that's going to land
for people who weren't there."
I think it was a "you had to be
there" kind of thing.
-I don't know.
I think I understand,
because if you actually
go back and watch
those episodes with the eye of
knowing you guys are
just staring at plastic boxes,
that seems, like, really rough.
-Yeah.
-That's like a reality show now.
It's not -- It's like,
"Who can last the longest
without losing their minds?"
-Who's gonna tap out?
-Yeah.
-Now, I want to say, Angela,
I feel like
I'm guilty of this, too,
which is -- You know, obviously,
the Angela in the show
was somebody who sort of
famously didn't like small talk.
And I think that because
you look like the character
and you have the same name,
people maybe assume
that was true of you, and, yet,
I've always found you
to be lovely.
Is that what you've found from
other fans, as well?
-People always think
I'm going to be a grump, right?
Also, I now have, like,
a resting bitch face.
After nine years,
my face just goes...
Like, and I don't even know.
But then, like, someone at
Target will be like,
"I love the show,"
and I'm like, "Thanks so much.
How are you doing?
How's your day?
Did you get bangs?
'Cause I feel like that frames
your face so cute."
And they're literally like,
"I've got to go."
So, I'm like, "Okay."
-And you --
your father actually --
Did he have
his own paper company
or work at a paper company?
-My father, Jim --
he worked at Boise Cascade,
and they make paper.
-Okay. So was he extra-proud
when you got your job
at a fictional paper company?
-Yeah, you know,
I asked the costume designer
if I could swipe one of
the Dunder Mifflin shirts.
This was early on,
before they were part of
the merchandise.
-Yeah. Before you guys
even had Internet.
-Exactly. And she gave it to me.
I gave it to him for Christmas.
And he would wear it,
and people would say,
"Oh, is that the company you
work for, Dunder Mifflin?"
And he would say,
"No, my daughter is
the receptionist there."
And then
people would be confused.
And then, as the show got more
popular, you know, then --
-They had to work
backwards to realize
he was bragging about you.
-Yes, exactly.
-When you rewatch the shows --
my first half of the question
is for you --
do you find the sort of
Jim-and-Pam romance
as sort of uncertain that
the audience did
as they were watching it unfold?
-Yeah, you know, so, for
our podcast, it's a rewatch,
and I haven't watched
most episodes
since they aired originally.
I always watched them
after they aired,
but back then, my brain
was so caught up with like,
"Oh, shoot, they cut that scene"
or, "Oh, wow,
that improv made it in.
That's so cool."
But now I feel like
I'm really watching it as
an audience member,
and it's very surreal.
I can't even believe it's me.
I can't believe I'm Pam
and I'm watching
this whole thing happen.
And it's like,
I know what's going to happen,
'cause I shot it,
but I'm still like...
[ Gasps ]
"...is he gonna tell her?
Why isn't he telling her?"
-Well, then
that just speaks to it.
-Yeah, I really get
the audience perspective
through this rewatch, for sure.
-Do people come up to you often
about Angela and Dwight?
-Here are the things I hear
about "Dwangela."
-Dwangela.
-I hear, "Ew!
Gross.
Why do we need to see that?"
-It's very nice that people feel
that they can be
honest with you.
-Yes.
-What has it been like,
this realization
that there's generations of
new fans who have watched this,
especially on streaming,
where they're just churning
through it so much faster,
obviously, than when it
aired over and over again?
Because it is, I think,
a show that has provided people
a lot of comfort over the years.
And it doesn't get less funny,
but they feel the same
connection to the characters.
What has that felt like?
Because you must hear it
all the time.
-It's really cool.
I mean, it makes me happy
to know that
parents we meet are now
watching it with their kids,
and they say, "Sometimes,
it's the only thing
we do together,
is we watch the show."
And I had shows
like that growing up.
Jenna and I both
have talked about that.
And it means a lot to us.
-Yeah. Yeah.
It's like --
I know that, sometimes,
we're just on in the background
while people are making dinner,
just keeping you company.
It's really cool, because you
can put it on at anytime.
You don't have to wait for
the next episode.
It's when you want it.
-It is a little weird,
though, sometimes.
Like, I had a kid come up to me,
and he said,
"You look like the older lady
from 'The Office.'
Are you the older lady?"
And I said,
"I am the older lady.
That's me."
-"And I've got bad news.
That was the
younger version of me."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-"Hey, are you the old guy from
'Weekend Update'?"
I'm like, "I'm gonna slap you."
Yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Hey, congratulations on
the book.
The podcast is wonderful.
And it's so wonderful to see
both of you again,
especially together.
-We love you!
-Thank you.
I love you both, as well.
You guys, Jenna Fischer
and Angela Kinsey.
"The Office BFFs"
is on sale now,
and all nine seasons of
"The Office"
are streaming on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."